est ce que vous connaissez ce qu'on
appelle le black phishing ça vous dit
quelque chose caroline après oui en fait
c'est un voilà c'est un des derniers
phénomènes instagram qui fait polémique
on va vous expliquer tout cela en détail
c'est bon soir sur canal + qui vous en
dit plus à la fin nous découvrons une
très jolie jeune fille métisse
le problème c'est qu'à l'origine emma
n'est pas vraiment métis et évidemment
ce qui fait polémique sur certaines
télévisions américaines pourquoi
font-ils ça certains disent que c'est
avant tout pour gagner en popularité à
voir davantage d'abonnés signer
davantage de contrats gagner davantage
d'argent donc elle adopte les codes de
la culture hip hop coop de 13 en vogue
dans la communauté afro américaine alors
grosse polémique bien évidemment qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
petit 1 caroline alors moi je ne
comprends pas ce débat mais je ne le
comprends pas
la jeune fille fait ce qu'elle veut avec
son visage son maquillage son bronzage
et paris hilton ont finalement que les
ans marc van sant en faisant en se
faisant passer pour une métisse ou pour
une personne de couleur
enfin et vous vous en place et elle
s'était passé elle s'était passé elle a
une base deux filles plutôt brune plutôt
typé 2,10 demain que je suis noir je ne
suis pas noir je vais pas prétendre que
ce souvent parce qu'ils aimaient et même
si elle avait envie de demeurer un nain
brême c'est leur envie de dire qu'elle
était métis ou que dans son adn avait un
point du mans de dari mot opposé par la
communauté noire et kiki qui dénoncent
ces influences blanche c'est qu'en fait
elle utilise tous les codes dits entre
guillemets cool et positif de la culture
black c'est à dire c'est le monde du hip
hop c'est la coolitude c'est tout ce que
vous voulez de positif est en revanche
quand elle se démaquiller qu'après elles
vont vivre leur petite vie de blanche
entre guillemets bell n'ont pas tous les
stigmates alors toutes les stigmates
cela dit elles sont elles dont elles
n'ont pas par exemple le délit de faciès
parlait par la police elles n'ont pas
tous les tous les trucs négatifs que
peuvent parfois rencontrées par pardon
mais la population noire
mais il n'ya pas polémique non vous n'y
a pas de
évident à tout et sur tous les sujets et
en l'occurrence là je n'en vois pas et
j'ai beau chercher je me dis faut
vraiment avoir un accord et que votre
avis
c'est petit mais est à 60 mois moi je
partage le bo caroline pascal hennuy
pendant longtemps on a considéré que la
couleur noire et est discriminante
donc il y avait une stigmatisation d'une
personne noire le fait de montrer que
cette fille elle se déguise pour être
plus belle en prenant rigueur de poids
je trouve que ça mais je trouve que
c'est flatteur savez il ya cette
histoire c'est plus beau qu est blanche
n'existe pas pour être plus belle se
déguise pour faire de la politique pour
essayer de choper des light des
commentaires et faire de l'argent avec
les marques bastien antoine griezmann il
a fait un black faye s'est déguisé à
orléans globe-trotter ça fait polémique
et a expliqué aussi mais que c'est pas
un déguisement de ce chemin
c'est simple c'est pas un déguisement
c'est le chant c'est comme ça c'est
comme un déguisement chez cette jeune
fille se disent absolument trouver alors
qu'il met en valeur certains traits de
2,2 à de barcelone munich
le parfum est un type un peu brun un peu
méditerranéen en mai claro elle est
aussi noir que moi je suis hétéro
telliano sature pas mais non mais c'est
vous dire que les wagons qu'elle devient
comme ça avec un petit peu de maquillage
et ses terres un extrait de ma djellaba
beige que jean quoi ça te dirai pas ce
que tu dis moi est ce que ça ne bouge ça
vous sonne vous choque pas tout de même
que elle elle monte entre guillemets sur
son identité a vraiment et de la même
manière qu'une qu'une qu'une fille
métisse ou un petit peu foncé de pau
aurait envie d'être de paraître un petit
peu plus blanches ça ne me choquerait
pas non plus je ne verrai pas la
polémique là d'un accord bon très bien
ça non mais moi je suis les ml non je
suis désolé effectivement comme elle le
dit elle le fait pour le côté un petit
peu cool pour gagner des legs pour
gagner là dessus à côté de ça elle se
tape à la discrimination elle se tape à
l'oeil le racisme elle se tape pas les
insultes voire pire elle a une vie super
cool les comptes à rendre certaines sort
et qu'elle a envie d'être blanche elle
est blanche
elle est allée noir on entend que ces
dlc stater c'est exactement comme les
mecs qui prennent la wii qui sépare les
pleins d'ordures montchamp non c'est
comme les gens qui prenaient place de
parking des personnes handicapées sans
point de leur handicap
j'ai à vous mettre d'accord non on va
demander par nos téléspectateurs à les y
réagit c'est parce que je pense que vous
aussi vous avez vraiment une opinion sur
cette histoire d'influencé pas la salle
elles sont nombreuses et il y en a
quelques-unes notamment aux états unis
qui ont choisi cette ce qu'on appelle
donc maintenant le black phishing je ne
connaissais pas cette elles ont peu
tendance
dites nous ce que vous en pensez
réagissait avec le hashtag c'est que des
lt je pense que effectivement chacun a
des opinions très tranchées lathus un
vrai débat russe